right good afternoon welcome along to
this meeting of the community wellbeing
committee uh I haven't received any
apologies in fact it looks like we have
a full house
which is great uh no Zoom attendees that
I've been informed of to remove on to
the presentation from Victoria and Emma
from the youth Council welcome along
thank you for giving up time during the
school holidays to to come along and be
here so it's a chance for you to talk to
us about what's been going on at youth
Council and in particularly the recent
trip to Wellington as well
Representatives I take the youth Council
report was read and we will go over some
of the points of the climate change
workshop and Festival of the future
today
um I'm Emma and I'm a first term
invercargill City youth counselor me and
Nobby Clark attended our second youth
council meeting and asked for us to
provide our thoughts on Council on
climate change
one of our youth councilors Lily was
unable to attend today but would like to
me to pass on her thoughts
her statement is I do I do think it is
really important that the economic
impacts of any climate change acts are
more heavily considered especially
considering that we're in recession I
don't think that is where money should
be going right now especially since we
are not not the largest contributors to
pollution in New Zealand
at our youth Council Workshop there was
a lot of agreement about climate fatigue
we often feel overwhelmed by the
bombardment of too much information and
requests to engage around this topic
it feels as if climate change is being
put on us as young people to solve we
hear from a lot of young people that
they don't feel climate change should be
their problem and believe that those in
power are the ones who could be putting
in more Mahi to make a significant
impact in reducing climate change
youth Council encourage Council to lay
out the priorities in decision making
and focus on purposeful action on
climate change reduction measures that
create a bigger impact rather than the
smallest things that might be easy wins
or good looks
uh Kia Ora I am Victoria and
unfortunately Liam who is the other
person that attended the Festival of the
future with me is not here today
um so on Thursday the 8th of June we
flew to Wellington to attend the
festival for the future which is a
two-day series of workshops and speaker
panels aimed at encouraging youth as
decision makers for the future
we are going to give an or I am going to
give an overview of some of the speakers
at the event and my thoughts on what we
learned so the first one is Dr Marsha
McCauley she had a provoking talk about
Ai and which is artificial intelligence
becoming teachers and this shed light on
what its usage in the future may look
like but I however do not agree because
it would outweigh the human ability to
teach students and it would not have the
same sort of affection or sympathy that
a human teacher can provide
Emmeline Pat dollstone spoke about ai's
role and groundbreaking environmental
technology and shared an example of
climate action work being developed with
NASA to reverse the effects of climate
change which also helps link to Emma's
topic and the youth counselors on
climate change and climate action
and lastly Laura O'Connor repair spoke
about climate Justice and the
decolonization and re-indigenization of
New Zealand
she had a really interesting Workshop
that I attended where we did many
um what's the word
many activities about what each
individual thought of aotearoa and how
we can help reverse some of the roles
and how introducing public holidays such
as matariki back into New Zealand
and that helps create the
re-indigenization of New Zealand and
help reverse the racial aspects of
climate Justice
questions counselors
um
so Victoria if I can follow up with your
visit to Wellington for the festival for
the future what was the average age of
the participants that were
um it was quite a large age range with I
saw quite a few teenagers there are
quite a few students in school uniforms
but there were also some older people
like the older said I saw was probably
about a 60 year old so it was a lot of
different people just going there to
learn
and
how do you feel about your voice now
that you've been at that event I believe
that the event really did help shed
light
um on the way that the world is working
now especially in aotearoa so I feel as
if it's increased my knowledge on some
of the aspects that they've talked about
which I can bring back to youth Council
so the sort of thing you'd encourage
future youth counselors to exhibit an
interest to go along and participate in
yes cool rare
um thank you very much I'm interested in
um email your comments about information
fatigue or overload in terms of climate
change when you mention the word um a
lot feel that that it's been dumped on
then for the interferks
um can you can you elaborate a little
bit
from what you mean to walk ah a lot of
questions come our way about what should
be done and yeah sometimes it feels like
we don't have the knowledge we aren't in
power with all of the stats and things
like that so it can be hard for us to
be able to make the change yeah so would
it be a more advantage to work with
mixed experiences to come to conclusions
on questions that you're given
absolutely yeah thank you
uh Evelyn
um
just following up on Ria's question
really and the fakaro that
um you're feeling
as an age group
over researched in this instance however
what I would I feel over researched
don't don't don't feel alone on that
um but I think that
I'd really like to understand how
as an older person
like your grandmother or
great-grandmother older person how am I
supposed to understand
what your expectations are of those of
us who are in the decision-making roles
what things you want us to consider on
your behalf because really what we're
doing here is we make decisions that for
probably we don't see the results for 20
or 30 years when it will be your problem
and I I wonder how we
how you think we should help you to
understand
that the decisions that we make now are
very long term some of the results won't
be seen for a time so therefore it's
really important I find for me that I
feel like a younger person is buying
into what we're discussing and deciding
how do we bridge that Gap yeah I think
it might
get my information it's
it's sometimes it's too quite a
High un not understandable for us that
we can't understand so that sometimes
puts us out of Interest we're like well
it doesn't matter to us we don't
understand what they're talking about so
people don't engage as to what might be
going on and the decisions you are
making so yeah so age-appropriate
language and age appropriate examples
yes yep absolutely and understanding
that it's we're not talking about
short-term fixes but long term yeah
making that making that clear when yeah
using the age-appropriate appropriate
language for
us so going back to the conference did
you did you think that that helped you
see that it was a long-term not a
short-term fix thing but a long-term
solution thing yes definitely
so how do you think that you translate
that to your fellow youth counselors and
the students that you're at your color
um
I think as someone who's already on the
youth Council just by having those
experiences I can just talk and use it
in other examples so when we talked
about the climate change I was I was not
there that day but when we speak about
it again I can bring up some of the
things for climate Justice that we spoke
about like I can possibly do some of the
activities that I did in the workshops
and help the youth Council and my fellow
peers understand it on that level as
well
coming thank you Mr chair so I've got
Trish Leslie knobby then Grant Trish
congratulations on your presentation
both of you you're a credit to yourself
Victoria I was really interested in your
comment about AI
um because obviously you know you don't
see it as being the whole thing of
education but what do you in the you
your other youth Council or your your
age group think about it being useful as
a tool to enhance your knowledge about
climate change or things like that do
you see that you could use it do you
discuss that
um I do not have the voice of everyone
in youth Council no but in my own
personal opinion I do believe that it
could help it because it's that
advancement in technology and with the
way that the climate is rising and all
of those sorts of things I think that it
will be a really useful tool in the
future if we can create that technology
and you see it's people like yourselves
who will be able to help us use it you
know because it's it's a Young Person's
tool really thank you
Leslie thanks cheer um it's probably
more a question for Emma because
Victoria said she wasn't there for the
discussion
um but I noticed in the written report
it says youth councilors urge Council to
explore more public awareness measures
for climate change and influence or
support Greener practices
so was there some specific discussion
about what public awareness measurement
measures you thought would work or what
specific support for greener practices
you would like to see
um I don't have an answer I'd have to go
back to youth Council and ask that
question as a group yeah yeah be
interested to get get the feedback
because if there are specific things
like
reporting to youth Council or things
that youth Council thinks could be
better publicly presented or you've got
specific ideas about The Greener
practices you would like to see
happening it would be good to feed that
detail to us yes absolutely and I'm sure
youth Council would be welcome to have
that conversation thank you Mia Clarke
yeah um
Victoria Neymar thanks for the feedback
um
I was really surprised in what you gave
us
um
I thought you might have come out with
some real green statement about where we
were going in the future but that wasn't
the case I think if I look at that and I
I run that past most of people around
this table with the exception of the
tree cutting in Queens Park
um I would have got the same from
calculus as well so I don't think it's
an age difference I just think people
have been overloaded information wise
about what is happening in our climate
change there's no coordination in New
Zealand so we were doing it smart we
wouldn't be talking about this today
we'd have a Regional Council that comes
to all the South and talking about
climate change so you'd hear the big
picture and what the cost of medication
was which is what you've raised you know
sometimes do you take the pain of trying
to do something green only to find out
that Brazil Australia America China
India
um doesn't if we don't do nothing and we
do nothing nothing will change unless
those big players do something
um so you know it was really pleasing to
get the report even though the report
wasn't all that helpful it just
reinforces me that because initially I
thought
when you hear about climate change and
you see what you see on TV you you tend
to see one of two people and don't take
this the wrong way you see teenagers
protesting really strongly about climate
change and then you look at people that
I guess are categorized as greens
and you don't see much of anything else
and so the fact that you've really come
up with I think what a lot of people
think is is really good
grunt
yeah thanks chip and yeah firstly like
to acknowledge the mayor in terms of
reaching out to youth Council and
providing the opportunity to come
through and well done to YouTube
presenting and I think you know I was
really impressed with the report you've
put together I think it I feel like it
gives good consideration to a number of
issues and gives greater insight to the
council so I think if you could take a
message back to youth Council the
process you're working through around
seeking out voice and trying to be
really representative about your
demographic I think is really valuable
to this Council so I would encourage you
to keep the work up well done on your
report in well done today I'm presenting
thank you easily oh thanks to you look I
just just think because of
some of the things that have been said I
do think to be fair the deputy mayor and
I do sit on a regional group
bits looking regionally
add all the hard questions around
climate change
and I I don't think it would be fear to
not acknowledge that there is a regional
grouping which includes manafinoa who's
looking the area at heart very hard at
the regional response
and there is a lot of data still to be
collected for a region to have the facts
we need to decide on priorities but
the region has seriously started
undertaking
response work
Tom might like to add to that but I just
thought it would be a Pity not to
mention that that is
really I Loosely see it so that there is
a regional Group which not only does
montefanoa support but actually
co-chairs
um which as looking uh how we can best
approach this
things that we can do today but more
importantly things that we can do over
the years to come and and I think the
the the the important thing for you to
think about when you talk about climate
fatigue in you and you talk about
um the fact that this is not really your
generation's problem I know so much your
problem but how do you solve it
I think it's important to realize that
you know this is this is something that
we're going to be working on
particularly in terms of adaptation
protecting the city for example building
walls to protect the city from sea rise
we're going to be working on this for
probably 50 years
so you went one of you two maybe I'll be
the mayor you know that builds the last
wall I I don't know but it is definitely
an issue that you that you as you become
adults are going to be working on I was
very very impressed here
um by the balance of this report
um I suppose before I started to read it
I thought it would be alarm
um but it's not very very balanced so
congratulations for coming back with
that so could you maybe just comment
though
um I I guess I don't talk to many people
your age except my granddaughters
but the the impression that I I suppose
I have got is that there's an enormous
amount of alarm among school children
and teenagers about climate change you
know alarm in the sense that you know
the world will end tomorrow
now this does not actually come through
from your report and you know that's
great because the world is not going
into model but can I can I just ask you
though is there a
other body either within the
um student counselor more broadly uh the
people that you see skill who are
alarmed in that way
at other people who just absolutely
think that the world is going to end
within the next short period
um there's definitely people that are
more alarmed than others I think
everyone has a feeling within them that
something needs to be done obviously
there are things being done but yeah
there are people that have stronger
feelings than others
does it worry you when you
speak to those or see that they that it
might go beyond just alarm and actually
become something which is beyond that
you know almost hysteria or something
from the community around me yeah okay
okay thank you granting me Clark what I
was just gonna ask is the youth Council
representation on your original climate
change at least no no no because it's
not the only youth Council either no no
but surely There's an opportunity to
engage youth in that we have talked
about the communication that will go out
and
included in that as Community boards
youth council's older groups so it has
been it has been talked about as the
need for
a communication plan
the priority setting
good idea Clark yeah just one thing I
forgot to mention before part of the
report back from the news Council talks
about uh the tree cutting in Queen's
Park and what the benefits are from that
from a climate change speaker just just
I guess for the record to acknowledge
that Steve's not cutting down all the
trees in Queens Park for that reason
most of them are for safety reasons and
some are for the um
um the airport requirement for a certain
Corridor for flights coming into the
city to have a reduction of the size of
some of the trees so we we've got no
choice on either of those two and of
course we will replant as part of the
process
thanks
councilor Cricket Just One Last Question
um thank you
um so I said as chair of um a board
additional body and in local government
New Zealand called young elective
members Network and we are a cohort of
all of the younger young elected members
which is anybody strangely enough under
the age of 40 but that is an elective
member and one of our kaupapa Poe is
climate change
and that's been fed up from all of our
young elected members across the country
is that that's something that they see
is really important
um so I found it really interesting to
read how balanced your report was as
well
um my question is more around
um
oh yeah I talk a lot from from the
questions that you've gotten here but
it's more around my reflection and
experience of with our young League
remembers group was more that
um
is it that you feel like it's not your
fault or your responsibility or the
younger generation's responsibility to
do climate mitigation or adaptation but
rather decision makers like us or
leaders or Civic leaders or central
government to do something the big
players to do something about it and it
should be them that are changing rather
than it being put all on your shoulders
or like the the younger generation's
shoulders but you still feel like
there's something that really needs to
be done
yeah I think we all feel that something
needs to be done sometimes it can just
can just cause of our age and that we
aren't in the positions to be able to
just make those changes and they can't
always just be made so yeah
so I guess I was just trying to clarify
that you still think it's extremely
important they just don't want it
absolutely yeah you don't want that you
don't want to feel like it's your
responsibility to do something about it
yes right
okay thank you
okay uh thank you very much uh Emma and
Victoria for uh coming along and
speaking to the report and answering the
questions there is a motion that we
receive the report uh are you moving
Grant yes thank you Ria
I'll put that all in favor I'm against
Kerry thank you very much resume the
holidays thank you Mia Clark just one
reflection as they go
um this is the second time we've we've
gone to this youth group did the same
thing for vibrancy around the city I
think it's a trend that needs to happen
we get a whole lot of information that
we didn't expect today
same when we get to the Rhiannon and her
team went to the um
issues around the inner city upgrade as
well should be a pattern that we should
continue to do
thanks thank you thank you thank you run
while the getting is good
counselors that brings us into
um
minutes we've got a group of minutes
from the city center heritage
subcommittee uh from Wednesday February
1st
moved councilor Campbell secondary
councilor Kate since you were both
apologies there was no oh sorry
councilor sober you were there so you
can move and somebody can take in Pro
former
hope they're all in
favored which brings us to the one that
did
um
on February the 8th
yes yes I think
so you can go to Tom thank you
put that all in favor I'm against
carried gosh we've been busy another
extraordinary meeting February 28th very
busy committee I'll move it
Tom that's what you get for adjusting
your glasses
uh put that all in favor
aye against carried March 23rd same
committing
which keeps us busy doesn't she doesn't
she Taskmaster
and
um
thank you questions
put the motion all in favor against
Carrie change of committee uh the
community well-being fund fresh
any questions
I'll put the motion all in favor against
carried we had a one meeting reprieved
before we come back to the city center
Heritage subcommittee May 3. I'll move
that also thank you seconded
I'm just gonna say cancer Randall but
he's done a bank already Tom thank you
questions put that all in favor
aye against Carrie Trish back to you for
the community wellbeing fund May 25th
and Signet grunt
questions
emotion all in favor
aye against carried same committee's
meeting on June 13. Trish secretary
Grant
the questions put it all in favor
aye aye Carrie
Leslie the city center Heritage
subcommittee meeting June 21. believe
that with pleasure thank you and
seconded Tom
put that all in favor
aye against carried
trash back to you it's like Gamma Tennis
welcome to Wimbledon since it's on at
the moment I'll move it thank you grant
seconds
questions
put it all in favor I I carried
minutes of the district licensing
committee meetings across June I'm happy
to move I'll second that thank you
Leslie
any questions
got that all in favor
carried no spelling Corrections this
time we were extra vigilant
uh youth Council we've done it
thanks for the heads up though Peter you
know you raised the bar for us
uh and the activities report
um taken as a block and really I'll ask
if there are any items in there that
anybody wishes to raise
Steve is there anything in particular
you'd like to signal
Trish I just I just got a question about
the increase in parking complaints is
that because of the new CBD
so through you chair no um parking
complaints are where someone has
contacted a counsel to complain about
someone else's parking we're not
entirely sure where there's been an
increase but it's it's noticeable I
think it's about 100 increase over the
year I can tell you
um but I know that some of the
businesses have seen a proliferation of
sub events packed and parking spaces all
day long
um or people parked in disability car
parks where they haven't had a Mobility
sticker so there's been more of those
coming through
uh Ria
okay
yeah thanks to a couple of questions
just with regards to
um the media stuff so 94 451 people
reached
is that individual people is that just
repeat
someone's come back to the page so it
could be the same person back few times
because that seems a lot
from the absence of Lisa who wants to
yeah I'll answer on Lisa's behalf
through you chair
um that's how many people have viewed
and as the page has gone past so they
haven't individually gone into our page
but for whatever reason that's come up
on their page and it's as they've scroll
past so that's individual people which
yes what a big reach isn't it yeah yeah
and then so secondary and just with
reflection on the youth Council like
how's their social or a media strategy
of social media strategy for reaching
young people
are we capturing that in our data like
we got a demographic yeah
yeah
Joe I will check that with Lisa to be
clear and come back to you on that but I
know the Instagram that has a younger
reach yeah the Instagram Pages yeah as
does The Tick Tock Alex yes um sorry in
the absence of Lisa as well um
absolutely you can break down
um any any post by analytic for
demographics so you can go into and see
um on each post who in which age range
which what gender but that's not where
they are that's not in the report no but
they they will have access to those
analytics the thing is you'd have to run
it for each social media platform rather
than presenting it combined and that's
quite a weighty report the information
is here I think it's important we
connect back to are we reaching these
people and that's the question to ask
yeah
I've got several questions so on the
issue the bluff service center and the
library there and hearing what we heard
from Richard this morning about the
Outreach of the library service my right
was assume that that 220 that's referred
for May last year
would be in a covert period or close to
and the comparable this year is 132 so
that's a significant drop
through you chair our um the library
numbers are collected manually by the
team in the bluff service center but yes
that is the numbers that come through
and visit the library at the back and it
is open all hours that the bluff service
center is open as well now
um and and again on page uh six of the
report
um an interesting statistic there about
Sandy Point and the people using that
for recreational purposes
the
um I guess the purple line significant
and a bit later on in the same same
report on the following page
because we've had this discussion about
before about whether we do anything
about the olderiti sand ex-gold course
and whether it needs to be mowed more
regularly or similar some of the noxious
plants taken out six thousand visitors
over a seven week period and that Golf
Course is significant
very significant best part of a thousand
a week
um so that was I guess just a reflection
the other issue is on on Russell Square
playground development
and I I don't see anything there about
the installation of a toilet
and last term we made a decision that in
this coming year which I I come in was
23 or 24 that we would actually have a
public toilet down the community has
been whistling out about that for quite
some time now
so if somebody can help me with that
Steve or somebody yeah God was also
reflected to those of us that attended a
meeting at noifa on Sunday as well Steve
yeah
um look I I had to come back to you on
that one for the next Community
well-being committee but um
sorry will you still be here then thank
you you will be
you know it has been raised by the
community quite a few times
thanks if you could come back with that
for the next minute Steve that'd be
great and the other the final issue for
me is as we consider um
um where to go to with uh hewakatuya
longer term which is not necessary in
the next year or two
um when I look at the results on page 15
of the report
and you look at the graph there and the
green line that goes across
that would imply in parts of early parts
of the year that we're getting visitor
rates of about 30 to 35 a day
which I would have thought a bit light
for a sort of investment we got there
and so if we're looking somewhere else
maybe one of the keys that we should be
looking for is maybe more attractions
purely based on location
as we go forward
you're not in for the record so it's
good Steve
and I guess the last thing for me was on
the very last bit about Pacifica that
George had come forward and asked for
some of the collection to be located
there as part of their commitment and
I'm pleased to see that some of it
some of the items have been uh placed
there I assume that'll be on a
rotational basis
Steve
Mr chair look yeah and Wayne also talked
about that this morning in the workshop
around our focus on Partnerships around
how we get our collection out to more
people more often yeah thank you
thanks Mr chair it's not a question it's
just a comment on the Innovative library
programs during May and I know during
June because I attended some of them
um just to say Well done to the library
they really are bringing forward the
Vibrant Community Hub in tension with
the programs that we're seeing reported
thanks for the feedback Evelyn
you said just a comment on the um
Sandy Point activation
which could the Hicks have been as a
result of the campaign that was going on
at the time I'd be more interested if it
was sustained so it's at this point it
seems like it's a
a blip that has happened because of a
tension that's been drawn to it if this
is sustained over a year it's a positive
thing if it's only over a couple of
months or three months then it's just
that it's it's something that happens
when something is drawn to people's
attention and they go out there the
awareness of it
um I'm more interested in looking at
where
um
where we're not seeing sustained
activity and wondering you know why not
um for instance
um the S3 walkway which is relatively
accessible without having to take a car
even for a lot of people who live over
that side of town where
um there's you know a little bit of
dropping off of activity whether it be
just it's seasonal or whatever I'd like
to see whether that can be those sorts
of places can be promoted and and
a better uptake because it's the ones
that are closest to the city
um Thompson's Bush doesn't get a great
deal of activity
um according to this
um and we don't even have the um
checks and trails within Queen's Park
recorded in this report so
for some people that is where they go
for their
um the recreational
um
fresh air time it would be quite
interesting to see if we could get some
sort of reflection on that as well
not sure how we gather that in some
senses because it's hard to pick which
tricks people are using use Thompson's
Bush as the example because it's close
to home for where I am and there's lots
of people in there but yeah so they can
place a track traffic counter on half a
dozen tricks so do we focus on different
tracks at different times or depending
on where we're feedback and everything
okay thank you thank you uh Trish then
Alex
um sorry
page 15. the visitor numbers are the
green line
at Hawaii
and so the lowest point would be a
thousand in February and then it's going
up
in my reading it correctly yes the green
line is the visitor number I mean you've
gone the glory track
sorry
well but you're correct Trish well if
I'm looking at February 23 as an example
where it dips down really low yeah it's
a thousand people a thousand people were
spread over 30 days 28 well right 28
days but say roughly 30 you're looking
at 30 to 35 people per day yeah which to
me is not a criticism where they're at
just that if we're going somewhere else
we might want a factor in yeah a venue
that might get more foot traffic through
it
you're looking at it for the map I'm
sorry yeah Alex then ring I just feel
really interested to know whether or not
the track counter at our 80 links X Golf
Course is specific for when people are
actually going out onto the fairways or
the previous Fairways rather than the
astronomy
um
all the other clubs that use that
facility because that may just be
skimming that data considerably Lobby
yeah I can help with that look um I'm
assuming unless Steve tells me otherwise
that it's on the road that leads down to
the is where they've been monitoring
um that over and above the dog walkers
who are significant I have to tell you
there's literally hundreds some days
going through these dog walking areas
they do have the astrological society
which is a very small
network of people and they do
occasionally have um
when you call them these cross-country
things orienteering but they're very few
for those events and they're not they're
not huge numbers either but the dog
walkers are significant I mean some
mornings is 30 and 40 dogs
it's huge
oh that's a nice introduction uh animal
control
[Laughter]
um
I'm just wondering where I would see and
that list under Animal Control
complaints against barking dogs you know
residential disturbances I just wondered
is that something that only would
present itself if it ended up in an
infringement or something or
or is that monitored
yes it is and and where do we see that
so the short answer is yes it is
monitored
um previously I don't think that we have
reported on it but by all means we can
continue to report on this yes it has
been yeah so if that could be broken out
next time that'd be useful that'd be
fantastic no problem
thanks good question any others
if not that brings us back to a motion
to move to receive the report which is
moved everyone's seeking to Trish
I'll put that all in favor against
Kerry thank you councilors we'll now
move to the public excluded session and
the reason that we're going into public
excluded is to receive PX minutes of the
extraordinary uh the meetings of the
city Heritage subcommittee meetings of
the community wellbeing fund and the
community wellbeing committee and for
the reasons as outlined I'll move that
we're going to public excluded
and we will reconvene for those public
excluded minutes at the conclusion of
infrastructure services for those that
have joined us on the live stream thank
you uh it's going to take us a couple of
minutes to swap over to the
infrastructural services committee
stream so you can pick up that meeting
on the other link thank you